oh so this arrived in the post some
while ago and you can see from it's the
nobel committee for physics and
chemistry the royal swedish academy of
science and on the bottom you see it
says
0.10144 out of a thousand so i think i
was number 144 on the list of a thousand
people they sent it out to secrecy
requirements
you can read that you should treat your
invitation and nominations highly
confidential so i'm not going to tell
you who i
voted for
it's one of those very closely guarded
secrets so nobody knows ahead of time
lots of people try to predict it
they almost always get it completely
wrong
and this year is no exception all the
predictions were not the people who
ended up winning the prize i believe
there is a panel that decides it
and they actually send out letters so i
actually got a letter from the nobel
foundation a year or so back which you
know caught some excitement because you
don't get letters from the nobel
foundation every day but all they they
weren't saying congratulations you've
won the prize they just said you know do
you have anyone you think who we should
be considering so they do go out and
consult and find out what you know what
the views are the scientific community
i've been asked for some suggestions uh
and for some views in the past
and i think what i've written down has
to remain secret for 50 years so i don't
think i'm going to tell you much about
that either they're saying who would you
think in your professional experience is
somebody who is deserving of a nobel
prize for whatever reason and then give
your reasons and cite the most
influential papers that lead you to do
this so that they have a a accurate
record of your opinion which is meant to
be independent of everybody else and
then you're giving the evidence so that
they can make a case and if enough
people write it in support of somebody
from all over the world then that gets
near the top of the list and then they
make a decision so today was the
announcement of the nobel prize for
physics um so over a series of a few
days the the prizes for all the
different areas that they actually give
out nobel prizes in are announced
so it's the physicist's turn today so
much excitement in the physics community
to figure out who's won who's now a
million dollars better off
so it was actually split it quite often
is a split award and it was split two
ways this time well it split between
three people but for two different
things so half of it went to a guy
called
charles cao for the invention of fiber
optics fibre technology and the other
half went to two physicists from the
bell labs in the united states william
boyle and george smith uh for the
invention of the ccd the charge coupled
device
it's a i mean it's strange because
actually in some sense i guess the pure
physicists are a little frustrated
because in some sense what's been given
the prize here is a piece of technology
a piece of engineering so it's it's an
interesting one but it's um perhaps a
little bit
unexpected in that um i think quite a
few people felt that the the the prize
might go for a rather more fundamental
discovery there are there are people
who've done fantastic work in
theoretical physics or in experimental
work but once in a while it's a good to
remind the public that what we do is uh
is a great practical use to the rest of
the world the the stuff that excites me
is not so much the engineering side of
physics it's it's really answering the
big deep fundamental questions and of
course we need the technology to do that
but it's
you know
getting at that the heart of matter
what is the structure of matter what is
the structure of the universe um
fundamental quantum mechanical problems
fundamental basic physics fundamental
physics problems um i guess that's what
excites me it doesn't excite you know
that might excite other physicists
rather less than it excites me but i
guess that's perhaps um my take on it i
mean fiber optics obviously has kind of
revolutionized a lot of things in terms
of broadband internet and cable
television and so on so it's been a huge
impact on the world um the other the ccd
that charged a couple devices also
actually had a huge impact in the world
the reason why you're able to film me at
the moment is because you're using a
camera with a ccd in the back in fact
you know all digital cameras use those
ccd devices
and so it's really the the device that
allows you to store images digitally
and obviously that has a huge impact in
astronomy as well uh in the old days
fortunately just before i started in
astronomy back in the 1980s we used to
record images on photographic plates and
so you can make nice pictures with
photographic plates but there's a couple
of problems with them personally they're
not very sensitive they're about one
percent as sensitive as a ccd is so
actually you have to observe the same
thing for 100 times as long with a
photographic plate
but the other thing is that if you take
a photographic plate you end up with a
photographic plate
and then there's not a whole lot you can
do with it really i mean you have to you
know you can look at it but that's about
it whereas with a ccd you end up with
the information in a digital form
and it's a beautiful digital form in the
sense that for every photon of light
that arrives you end up recording one
count so you really are seeing the light
as it arrives and really recording a
completely undistorted image of the
object that you're looking at but in
essence what happens is every time a
photon a particle of light comes in it
liberates one electron within a pixel
within one of the elements of this
device
and so really you're turning light into
charge and then you just need to measure
the amount of charge you've recorded and
that tells you how much light's arrived
and hence how bright the thing was that
you were looking at
um so what a fiber optic is is basically
it's a strand of gloss
and the beauty is of strands of glass is
that you can actually get light to
travel along them even when the strand
isn't straight so you can use light to
transfer information around very quickly
obviously at the speed of light
but the elegant thing about the fiber
optics is that you don't have to have
the light traveling in straight lines it
will actually follow the curve of the
glass
and physically the way that works is
through a process called total internal
reflection well this is a demonstration
of an optical fiber in action our fiber
isn't a slender gas glass thing
that will be used in communications
rather it's a bent perspex rod but the
principles are just the same
the light's going to bounce around
inside and we're going to send an audio
signal
through this rod now we need a sound
source of course and that's provided by
the the radio here rather old school
thing and the sound comes out of the
radio via this cable here
into this little piece of circuitry and
all that does is it just turns the
signal the sound signal into a light
signal essentially you can see a little
light emitting diode here and that's
producing an amount of light and the
amount of light varies depending on how
big a voltage or how big the signal is
coming out of the radio here
then the light once we've aligned it
will travel up the optical fiber our
bent perspex rod going all around
obviously isn't straight so it has to
bounce off the sides and there's a
something called total internal
reflection which is the physics that
drives all optical fibers and if you've
ever dived into a swimming pool and
looked up at the surface if you look at
kind of an oblique angle to the surface
you actually end up seeing a reflection
the light doesn't actually travel
through the surface of the water it
actually gets reflected internally
reflected and the way a fibre optic work
is as the light travels along every time
it hits the side it basically gets
internally reflected so the light sort
of bounces its way down the fibre optic
cable and at the very end here
we have this little goldy looking thing
is a photosensitive diode and when the
light when we align it the light will
hit that little diode and it'll generate
a current
and the amount of current is
proportional to the amount of light
so that's the signal is recovered back
and we can feed that into a pair of
speakers here
and hear the sound hopefully the
original sound
so what we'll do is we'll turn up our
volume on the speakers
we'll align
the diode at this end with the end of
the fiber so the light is now going into
the end of the fiber traveling along but
of course once it reaches this end it
isn't yet uh traveling into our photo
diode and we'll push
the diode up again
and if you listen carefully
ever tried the cabbage diet there we go
stinky diet pills
that's local radio coming through our
optical fiber